[Music]
let's go to ann in all four cities in
iowa in the quad cities what's up ann
hi
how are
you i'm freaking out right now i'm
really excited me too i am freaking out
as well
why are you freaking out
um
just there's a lot going on but before i
get to that i will go straight to my
question i just want to say thank you so
much for all the work that you do and
are doing um it's been really meaningful
for me thank you that's meaningful for
me too for real because this hap the
whole thing happens in a vacuum we're
like locked in a studio here and james
doesn't let me listen to the show and so
um that means the world to me i'm
grateful for that
yeah so
um a couple of months ago my dad passed
away and so i'm still reading that i'm
sorry
how do you pass away
um so i'm not sure how much detail i
should get into but um essentially his
lungs gave out on him whatever you're
comfortable with
he had coveted and then it was a battle
and then he
he just got tired
um so i'm still working through that and
then um did you get to see him
i'm sorry i'm sorry i keep interrupting
you i just i'm trying to get a a
full picture did you get to see him or
did he have to yeah did he die by
himself
um so
early in the process when he was first
uh hospitalized you know we were able to
see him and and speak with him and he
was awake and then he ended up being
sedated and
that's how he passed um he was he was
alone he was out of state okay i'm sorry
yeah it was tough it really was and it
still is right yeah yeah it is it is
all right so then the next
yeah so then as i was walking through
that um i unexpectedly found out that i
was pregnant and was processing that
and then within a time frame of about
four days i found out i was pregnant
found out my numbers were not where they
should be and um ended up being an
ectopic pregnancy and so i miscarried
um
and that was kind of traumatic but it
was it required surgery and things
um not kind of
it was tragic yeah it sucked suck suck
suck
go in knowing that's the that the end
result there right
yes did you lose your flipping two
yes i lost one of my fallopian tubes
okay
so you lost an organ in the deal
yes i did
um so was this pregnancy exciting was
this pregnancy scary or are you all by
yourself you got other kids like give me
the context for the pregnancy
yeah so it was exciting unexpected but
exciting um i do have two other children
one is four and one is almost two
um and we were not planning on having
any more children so we were kind of
blindsided by it but once we found out
we were excited yeah yeah
um
did you did you land on a name
no we we didn't even get that far the
furthest we get was me
upset because we were going to have to
buy a van and i really didn't want a
band
you would have been an awesome van mom
ann
yeah and with the fans that would have
been awesome yeah right yeah that would
have been a great bumper sticker exactly
oh man
yes but my question is um
i like i didn't want to have another
child but after having gone through all
of this i kind of want to have another
child
and
i'm thinking is that selfish is that
something that i shouldn't even be
thinking of because i've gone through so
much within the past couple of months
um but that's kind of where i'm at yeah
so
first and foremost
your feelings are your feelings and your
thoughts or your thoughts
they don't always tell us the truth but
they're real
does that make sense
it does so i want you whatever you're
feeling whatever you're thinking
whatever you desire now is all fine it's
all good
and you have been through
hell
because my guess is before your dad
passed it was hell and trying to love
somebody far away and whenever parents
pass away
it's always a mixture of
ugh and heartbreak and all you know you
know what i mean you just went through
all that all that stuff
and then you got two little ones that
you're trying to parent and you got some
knucklehead husband you're trying to
probably parent to right all the stuff
and then
man
a corner of your heart got peeled back
and you didn't even know it was there
and all of a sudden it's
so every
everything you're feeling is great
and so hear me say if you want to have
another baby have another baby
if you found something new about
yourself that's one of life's great
adventures man go for
it and if you don't then don't the the
advice i got from
when i was walking through this very
similar situation to you ectopic
pregnancy whole thing
um
the advice i got was from the a
counselor that i trust deeply with my
life and he's the guy who trained me on
crisis stuff
um he said his recommendation is to wait
six months to make any big life
decisions after trauma
yeah
and so um i know i know families who
have
have one of my close friends lost
um a pregnancy at the very very very end
like month eight and a half or month
nine
and man they were pregnant soon after
great great
adventure for their family
um
and then others wait years so
everybody's different grief is different
for everybody
what's your husband think about it
he doesn't want to have another child um
and
we knew that you know before we we got
pregnant but
um he's willing to talk about it okay
here's here's the i'm not gonna tell you
how to do grief because grief is yours
okay
um i'll give you a couple of
recommendations but i will give you one
you've got to you've got to you've got
to is that fair
yeah okay
first one is don't try to get past this
stuff
fully experience it
yeah and keep doing your life
what do i mean by that
on sad days feel real real sad let that
sad just be a part of you for a season
when you think about your dad and your
heart just feels like always a thousand
pounds feel that don't try to don't try
to
brush it off
and
make sure you go for a walk that evening
or you go do the class that you've
signed up for or you and your husband go
play a game whatever the thing is okay
so it's both and
and the two conv the two competing
wisdoms right now in our culture are
just suck it up and crush it and that
will go away or
you you do you and you just sit there
and let it wash over you for the next
five years and whenever you know what i
mean and what i want to say is there's a
third way it's both and okay
don't ignore that stuff because it will
weigh you down over time and don't let
it take over your life it's both and
and there will be days when it takes
over great get up the next day and have
a good day the next day
the second thing is this
you've got to got to got to let your
husband know what you're feeling
the thing that families even on
something like a miscarriage
is people grieve differently and they
start hiding their grief from one
another they start hiding their tomorrow
plans from one another and then all of a
sudden boom we are two inches apart and
2 000 miles away from our loved ones
sitting on the same couch right
yeah and so you've got to be honest with
him do you feel safe enough to be honest
with him
i do and you've been so supportive
awesome
oh that's so so so good
and then here's my other recommendation
this can be this can be um controversial
blah blah it's
whatever i don't care um
i would
give yourself the opportunity to name
this child
and to write this child letter
about how much you miss them
and
you didn't get to get to meet them but
here's here's brothers and sisters
here's what life is is where we live a
just a conversation with
and it sounds counterintuitive like why
would i do that to myself why would i go
into that
what i'm hearing from you is your body's
already there your just heart and mind
isn't there
and so i would take that journey into
that conversation with a letter i'd
write your dad a letter have you done
that yet
yeah um
i started a journal
when he was sick and i just was was
keeping things that i wanted to share
with him there and
after he passed i continue to write to
him just in a different context good
good good good
have you told them the bad stuff too
not yet i haven't gotten there okay make
sure you do that because dads aren't
perfect
and your body will feel the gap between
a guy that you had some major
frustrations with probably not everybody
but probably am i am i onto something
no i mean he was great um but we were so
much alike that
we bought it had pulled out there you go
that's right or two offensive linemen
just banging heads against each other so
um
make sure you honor the tough stuff too
because both and because
he helped
he helped
mold into who you are both the good
stuff and the tough stuff the stuff that
your husband's like oh my gosh why that
you know some of that came from old man
right so honor all of it he reminds me
write him a letter about what you
learned from him what you didn't learn
from him what you should have learned
from him what you miss about him what
you are not going to miss about it's the
whole human experience okay yeah and
good for you for writing a journal what
a gift and i recommend anybody going
through that start that journal and
continue to write right
um
the the babies that we've lost in
miscarriage i've got their names
tattooed on my body
that's how big of a deal i think that is
okay
is to own it and to they're a part of us
and then we're gonna go on about what
tomorrow's gonna look like but that's
that's that's how me and my family
handled that um and then if you wanna
have another baby having a baby
have that conversation with your husband
and be all in is that cool
yeah i can do that
hear me say this there is no wrong way
to do this other than keeping secrets
okay
okay keeping secrets is the wrong thing
to do everything else
is a part of the the healing process
here
if you want another baby be honest with
them about have another baby and if it
doesn't end up happening it doesn't end
up happening um but good for you
so
can i just tell you
brother to sister i'm sorry my heart's
broken for you
thank you
and it doesn't bring anybody back
doesn't make anything better but once
you know you're not alone and that that
grief is hard i'm sorry
thanks for being with us
well thank you um
for
walking through it with me um i i don't
feel alone um
and i think that's part of the reason
that you know i've started to open up
and share some of my story with others
because
i don't feel alone but i know that
others might you know who are walking
through a similar situation so
yeah
and in the process of wanting to help
other people
don't forget to start with you
your oxygen mask goes on first
you deserve a night of sleep you need to
take care of your body you need to take
care of your relationships and then
you're strong enough well enough to love
and walk alongside other people as they
their dark days descend on them and we
all have them i'm grateful for your
heart grateful for you yeah you're not
crazy
grief's uh you're in tough season tough
season tough season but uh man it's been
an honor talking with you